[Musique]
en conclusion de cette curieuse années
2020 est évidemment en prévision du
passage vers l'année 2000 21 en
martinique la première vous offre ce
soir un voyage des plus audacieux et
mélodieux à travers les plus beaux
décors de notre île
préparez-vous à aborder de la manière la
plus sereine qui soit cette nouvelle
année avec nos mélodies vue du ciel pour
renforcer notre soutien au monde
artistique et culturelle cette émission
est une ballade emmenés par de jeunes
artistes émergents martiniquais parmi
eux
lauriane zachary arnold cyril cinélu
jeanne beaudry d'avis de badges là ou
encore mêlée et capelli il signe la bo
de notre voyage et surtout nous
prendrons l'altitude nécessaires pour
voir au delà de l'horizon 2021
je suis fière pellon bienvenue dans
mélodie vue du ciel
bon réveillon
[Musique]
derrière moi tout cela c'est encore ben
moins qu'à songer - qu'attend tout ça
qui fait moins monte et descend et on la
voit toujours dit - pas faim et puis
battre la vie à trois points qui bout de
six ans belle fête qui pendent les mois
tombé moins rêver cherche un b - palerme
anti saliver m'en doutais qu'ils
délaissent aphonie délai flou comme
essien là encore c'est passé mis en
lumière en trees
mais moins qu'à songer sa nou té fé fine
ou pâté jean mentha veillait et biwako
nouveau lot monnaie
parce si même les liens font notre passé
et mon cerveau n'ayant été
au petit éclate à la clé
où
auj
ils nous ont même empêché l'algérie
détient b et ping adéquat sans doute et
qui ni délai sa faune et de la flore
comme et si on l'a encore s'est passé ni
en ligne est en trio
[Musique]
oh
façon ses limites en 13 ans
les fafn et des locaux mais si on nous
l'a encore sais pas s'ils n'étaient en
ligne entre et sort
oh
[Musique]
o o
oh
télé moi tout seul 400 g - qu'attendent
tous ça qui fait moins monte et descend
mais en la voiture je t'aime un parfum
et puis pat la vie à pouvoir prendre qui
bons essais en pelles flec et pan aïoli
mis en fonctionnement
l'été ligne
[Musique]
oh
o o
était en ligne
[Musique]
e
le monde révèle matin
mais qu'apprend botola
à moins que malgré moi
fait que moins bien les animaux way les
6èmes finir mais qu'apprend on voit
à
- calais béziers - moment
en décourage hallade
finissez
couper pour - jambonnière
ma bassin
santi
[Musique]
le musée -
je vais faire moins poussées
[Musique]
riba - bras brûlés
imam wells on est moins bien
résistant d'expression
[Musique]
tout à fait pour lui
vous
toi
m
[Musique]
- l'attend
qui ça
les soirs
[Musique]
quitte à nous
ou des frais
[Musique]
dans les archives
dans les énergies
[Musique]
nono c'est moi qui l'ait
chez nous pas différent
bon j'ai fait
pour vous ça
il va nous
là
aussi c'est moi
et
[Musique]
là
at on fait
et jamais
non
[Musique]
- c'est ans
voir mais
m
où et moi non plus
à
[Musique]
ces micro noblin
oh
aux abris
[Musique]
boiseries les bois
bois brûlé brûlé
et
[Musique]
oh
e
tidjy rimer
[Musique]
enfin carla m'a dit ladd a songé
l'étranger les gi jane qui forme aussi
pourtant les mieux la ville 24 ans et
m'a dit ce format à nice elle m'a dit
c'est parce qu'ils pensent mais bon
c'est madhi ses formes sont allés en
scène un disque en forme c'est devant
qu'il y aller jeudi matignon
quand c'est toi qui tiens
v à rabat est aussi le nom de nuit
en tout cas pas une chimère ou même avis
et formats aux annonces et m'a dit c'est
parce qu'étant puis elle m'a dit c'est
faux c'est bon
[Musique]
en vain salegy d'enfants tués au fond du
bassin
[Musique]
pour
mady se lave au coeur des songes où
dorment les secrètes une femme histoire
distraite une âme dit il
burris y en a en silence maggie may n'a
tellement houba samba le fait que la
fois pour la forme sagaie zaïre mais
mohammadi ses formes moncany mons et m'a
dit c'est parce que pendant mon service
et pense à cette époque
[Musique]
l'indicé maman c'est le moment
enfin châtiment des maris femme sally
nouveau congrès en partie
[Musique]
enfin ça
mais c'est madhi ces formats
passiez pas
[Musique]
je
ces formats
fa suivant des forces de vente le vit
[Musique]
cela dit ces formats
ben ali afin qu'ils libèrent forme qui a
lavé
[Musique]
non
oui
ou au bout à bout peuvent à chaud remain
in love you divine maîtres du compas
nadon ou bannis pour self esteem
ouvrables ou belle inside handidanse a
averti me henri spaak matrix au passé
l'équipe les esprits
dior même le barney symptômes je ne veux
pas d'odeur demolition man mais justin
king qui s'est calmé la flamme c'est
lorsque tu ayant mode paillat bonne bo
bobo ou sian mélange mami wata kefaya
vous savez nos mini key alors qu une
gomme et y un gipsy like gipsy pourquoi
pois brocolis black gipsy l'ingouchie
psy
mais l'année mais là mais la mélanine
c'est pas que l'anah est qu on sait que
les étoiles wii black skin like i never
mind c'est pas une question de race mais
de timing goddess of wind soleil ou la
ligne ou car either chaque fois l'hymne
papy c'est clair il faut pour s'offrir
aux cabines si je me suis fait mieux en
laye en canine à wright au même le
parquet sa femme donne tu ne veux pas
d'un grand pôle de demolition man mais
juste qui s'est calmé la place
l'autre est payante bayamon waouh ou
celio ménages mamie ouate un équipage à
bord
vous savez nom biblique est alors quid
go
c'est là que gypsy punk whaou et michael
gipsy encore au monde s'est fait bouffer
mugello ce haka bis whispers poussé mme
algier à cannes robin thicke ou miyamoto
world we speak
quand tu parles s'apaiser mais délaisse
à douai trade patriarcale et où était
discrète pas souligner un fayat qui paie
plus les systèmes mieux
ça y est
où j'en fais pas ça sert pas qu'à des
dies même le connaissent un boom donnes
tu ne veux pas de lambeaux demolition
man justin king dont tu s'est calmé la
flotte l'hostis meilhan may cry hameau
seillant mélange mamie ouate 1 et puis
fargo
où ça fait nommer nikkei alors windows
et bien que gipsy de l'aqueduc six bons
mois pour bois et bien que jobs c'est là
que du psy
même le bât blesse abandonne tu ne veux
pas leur monnaie demolition man justin
king dentu s'est calmé la flemme
derrière même le ban et s'abandonne tu
ne veux pas d'un mode demolition man
justin king dont tu sais car mais la
flamme tender lorsqu'il est en mode
fayat pelouse
[Musique]
auj
oh
[Musique]
où
tif la belle jolie fragile aussi capa
façon ont tous à la nature veuillez
malik amour
un chat isoler ses mains et kendall inga
sous revue négative et il me dit fais la
vie
e
[Musique]
où les mango
où les monts au lait ou les monts
vous voulez mongole et
et où les mots
où l'air
où les mots
rouler ou les mambos voulait tiflet
vendit bien changé reanbell mango
magnéto et l'appui consacre iccat et et
santi lâchait qui ont dit dans les cas
péter wei wei les éléments j'ai senti ou
santis et les 6es main en main un excès
des années beaucoup me mets au smic et
douce
[Musique]
jouer aux eaux
où les mon goût
où les mots ou les
où les mondiaux
où les mangues au volet où les mots
où les mangues ou les
où les mangues ou rouler
où les mango ou les monts goa et car les
ics à kateb lives ans et qui bannit
engagés derrière
isaac honnête à une misère à connaître
la glisse ou fait il avoit bientôt tous
les mondiaux a besoin en laye où vous
êtes vous allé si loin où les gars
voulaient way où les mots
où les monts
les où les monts
où les montroulez où les mango
où les mangues au lait ou les mongols et
voulait m'enrôler sait où les gares ou
les messieurs avizois manger il faut
mimer les allées se voulait y aller
c'est où les gars voulaient
messieurs vous mangez il faut qu'on me
met les allées où les monts où les mots
ou les où les routes ou les monts rouler
ou les membres
ou la mongolie où les mungo
l'est
[Musique]
et
antoine attend de moi songer
je dis pas chou
on est vite
moi
regardez mes semblables car du tracé
prend l'or mois
- souris
découpez-les en est où
m
tous échelons
dix mois
et si toutes les hostilités
don
- jouer ma charge
grandis kung fu
- ça tout ça si côté barreaux sciés
hulu est tombé
tombé à l'eau
ce qu'a plaidé
fichage de l'air et faire voter
claire répit sera tiré
coc
[Musique]
m
domi et ou qu'on les en dépit des
acheteurs et ussel en juin où ses côtés
m'a cassé des coûts riber
tous
et
me longtemps six mois et objet
pour exemple et
aux fins il
m'arriver touché quand l amour capoter
m'a caressée
ch.d
sa force aujourd'hui moins que doué
[Musique]
il vient aussi beauté
les motiver
et aussi à repérer
aussi l'élite
[Musique]
évoquant les intitulés h 15 coc horizon
où ses côtés voix cassée et privés
non
oh
[Musique]
si les islamistes ont été pichichi
c'est ou servis soit on sait côté m'a
cassé pour v
non
un an
[Musique]
c'était à nous était chez nous dit c'est
notre terre notre place notre vie mais
sans lui rien ne me retient plus pari
tenu pari perdu
j'ai perdu le bourg il envie et je n'y
vois plus que du gris j'ai oublié le nom
des rues
pari tenu pari perdu
pas un recoin pas une place où l'on n'a
pas laissé de traces
pourtant la ville toute entière est
devenue une étrangère le lien était bien
trop fragile entre mon coeur cette ville
sans son amour l'amour n'est plus
pari tenu pari perdu je ne me sens plus
à l'abri
j'ai froid j'ai le mal du pays mme habib
sy ne me ressemble plus pari tenu pari p
pas en coin pas d'une place où l'on n'a
pas laissé de traces pourtant à vis de
toute entière est devenue une étrangère
j'ai vu ton reflet dans ses yeux
paris j'ai vu son regard amoureux
mais le jour où il est parti l'a emporté
avec lui ce que pour toi j'ai ressenti
je ne ressens plus aujourd'hui
que des chagrins italie c'est décidé je
ne reviendrai plus
pari tenu pari perdu
avant quoi passer de place aux l'on n'a
pas laissé nos traces
pourtant la ville toute entière est venu
et mme étrangers
quitter les lieux laisser la place et
passer tout eu
nos traces
puisque l'ue toute entière est devenu
une étrange j'aime
[Musique]
c'est léger et frais
tous ces scènes
fo nou aller devant
par exemple pas les temps
[Musique]
sinistre assez bizarres et me traverser
la mer
outre l'arrivée promise
à ce fonds
ce qui a changé merci dooley trop fort
même si aucun viol anal et yvan
à
manal et ou pas
ouah
nous on a des lois
wada les douves à tout vent
tout va
même si leur astre faut même si
quelqu'un s'agit
ça coûtait au cas les femmes
les devants en paquets qu'elle chante
soleil en tête son toupet de renouveler
savent qu'ils t'ont chimie un lac et
bulut nous calme hsbc considère la
seconde
novak a trouvé réponse y aie évalue bon
sens en changer pour notre jeu fan ou
pas même si le ratio fort c'est pierre
schaller même si de la transforme aussi
en camion
[Musique]
souvent
et souvent
oh
on a les doublons
à tous vents souvent
[Musique]
trop longtemps pas mais je n'y étais
pour m'appuyer pompiers tout le monde
veut les mater qu'ont fait ces mêmes
pages répond aux questions restées sans
réponse irony bon sens tout en coûtant
tout au moins tout le moins besoin dans
celle qui a échoué deux fois brisée et
chaparral et puis on va t on aller
à
oh
le banc
[Musique]
analyse
oh
[Musique]
ah ah
à
[Musique]
oui
avi
manalich souvent
laurent
devant
ah ah
dans le monde
[Musique]
on va
m
[Musique]
on
simone et moi qui sommes allés
[Musique]
simon et moi qui sommes les fêtes nous
parler
[Musique]
si le bailleur tandis
c'est vital à montvillers soit ian
whitten a coûté mois
c'est ça la vie
vous dites
ok
de l'enm ou à gauche est devenu 100 ch
et ça tous les jours pour nous tromper
la vie y'a violents mettant moore part
nous chanter ça tous les jours pour nous
toutes et tous est la vie iard
s'immoler
fait chier
[Musique]
tél
c'est là
[Musique]
et puis
non
[Musique]
soudés et six mois
ça nous y voici
[Musique]
avait il en remet
e
m
[Musique]
e
tp page est atteint
la fim
il entend très longtemps
[Musique]
maccarini
mais ils ont manqué aux coupes et
enfourner
il croit aux hautes orientations temps
où ça changer la vie nous au mode
orientale
filles exploitées a souvent l'habillage
ah ok tout vent d'autan
il est toujours rêvé est mise et c'est
papa à manama et wissous fait ses filles
c'est pas mon premier fois donc à tomber
l'état tombé l'état on est content
bâtiment on est heureux sous marin
calcetto bio bio manouche et fois moins
meilhon et lecce - les monuments you
call it amelio laisse attirer les filles
aux enchères et les papas s'il boutique
mais ça ça te qui passa passa
maillaud par couper mon bel amour et
animale courbet boîte et c'est tout à
fait les mêmes si vous aimez ça s'anime
à ce passage
[Musique]
oh ouais
au moins nous c'est qu'ils savent c'est
ça qui passa passa
oh ouais
mouais
[Musique]
ce n'est pas ce passage il s'est foutu
que tu t'en as des as
et c'est puccino cadiou dans la vie et
c'est pucci maucaillou donne
liam messam mustapha ce clip ascm assad
et c'est foutu manqué de temps
et c'est bon tu manques à des eaux dans
la ville etc puccino gadio dans la vie à
messali sasaki passe pas ça
denis
il y
[Musique]
là
il
oui
la mort à maghama et wii sont faits ces
filles
c'est pas vos premiers x n'ont qu'à
tomber l'état tomber les tabous vraiment
pas timoré course au maracanã cette
opinion globale chez fois moins
meilhon et les témoins les pros du
maillot carlita maillaud les statuts ont
été placées guillot préfet et massimo
guéri mais sammy sosa ce qui passe pas
ça
beaucoup
en mai la boue est il mal coupé protéger
tout en chef et les magazines séries
mais ça me sauve sa famille passa passa
au
tout ça
moussa saw vi afssa qui passe pas ça et
c'est foutu manque un duo dans la vie
y'a et ses coutumes aucun doute ans
lundi a été touché un caillou dans la
vie
mais ça ça
ça qui passa
[Musique]
passeur
kron
on
où
[Musique]
donc
oh yeah
oh
[Musique]
each day the place une soif home away
un ghetto qui allie malades
et ma fille marine systems que tu as to
[Musique]
which you
malo ou au mans et au water-polo is well
and a new way to go à doha qat doute
jouée dos
[Musique]
human o o
mallat
guardini one to me
[Musique]
dans cet esprit ou bien à la j'ai dit ma
nous envoie même si aujourd hui en
message à oulu à ces énergies capoter
fois tout la fois c'est confiance en la
vie
en face la face parce que la vie à pile
ou face parce que nous paye parce que
nous paie pas combien pas tomber en
ruine et v aura pour bien fait dit
toujours tout neuf
c'est ou quatre ans - fausse la seu
capote et lumière en cadiou mais si mais
si mais si vous tous à ouffet romain
mary lou
alors
l'eau le haut
guillaume loriot dit on i want you my
love you lose you man
oh et
ea ea
et hélas
et est il ya
et
aie aie aie aie
ja
hé hé
[Musique]
je t il se blesse une soa folle au
marais
[Musique]
ana
racontez pas du tout statut d'oea
pauvres ou très peu des actufoot ouverte
à toutes et à tous
lou l'eau non notre lolo audio my own
you die en limo nyon matin
[Musique]
lolo
non
[Musique]
oh
each day se placer et stay se placer
each day et se placer
et dix blessés nos guides t au
[Musique]
on
ve
shor
stevie g ces belles parts chaque pack à
qui tu te casses joue bach à monter
monocell censier ainsi nick lowe à tous
grâce iodine océan quotas dans l'océan
mais l'océan c'est plié coûte les voiles
racheter à nab en détente chez nous
toujours en route de quitter qu'à monter
mon petit cabinet vite c'est ben moi
c'est seulement ni légumes et si vous
cachez lumière a pas de panique nous
fait épiler des poufs et que nous
ferions costumes evandro imaginez chaque
mot des matches et s'ils imposent à quoi
nous cardillo
si même été à tout moment comme ça nous
laisse
oui nos aïeux seyssel l'église ont fait
à tout moment chaque mode chez nous
yes we know
[Musique]
mais c'est chez nous a indiqué mme
poésie comme chez nous
et oui nous en harmonie qui veut nous
voulons en bonis enclos un concours
s'est fait à d'un plot nous car le doute
chez nous et pique ou hp l'ohio tombé à
klaus wyn evans denis gauthier mammouth
a pâli touba conduisent au 15 août et à
la souris h toujours café ni batterie
comme si faune uwa tonnes sur les rives
in pour dit
je souhaite la vision de l'horizon un
horizon vert de guérison que ce qui nous
maintient la tête sous l'eau ne
connaissent ni infini pour l'opus que
l'harmonie nos soustraire de la division
que la lumière guide nous convient pas
dit que nos générations se passe le
flambeau de gains
ils ont longtemps ça dans l'est
be nice we know ariane c'est celle
déguise en fait à tout moment et chaque
mode chez nous
d
[Musique]
yes we nominaux n'y mettez jane moinard
pouvez vous nous en harmonie
et
non
[Musique]
mais
i
à tout moment
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
où
d'ailleurs je sais que dans une autre
vie on se reverra et même si ce n'est
pas vrai qui vivra verra pendant les
chèques comme leçon de vie pour pas
baissé pas que la peur nous abandonne et
qu'on se pardonne mais pour l'instant ni
cette vie alléluia maps est payant
d'économie d'amont pour soir c'est la
vérité c'est nous mêmes
on peut choisir
pour moi
[Musique]
c'est celle là
en fait à tout moment les 5%
[Musique]
yes we know it au public
mais c'est chez nous
poésie
baden où vivait
pour nous
au monde
sam
ces lobbies oui
c'est celle
au fait à temps
m
[Musique]
nier
yes we know
mais ted chaîne
impôts etc
nous vivons nous n'allons monnaie
il
mon
ni
[Musique]
at monte monte monte
salut c'est cyril cinélu c'est à mon
tour de vous souhaiter une très bonne
année 2021 qu'elle soit pleine de
réussite de succès d'amour et surtout la
santé je vous embrasse très très fort à
très bientôt
et voilà que cette année 2020 si
particulière s'achève sous qu'on sache
réellement ce qu'on retrouvera de
l'autre côté
pour ma part je souhaite à tous les
téléspectateurs de martinique 1ère de
pouvoir commencer cette année 2021
dans l'amour le coeur chargé d'énergie
positive d'optimisme des déterminations
de générosité de joie je vous adresse
tous mes voeux les plus sincères et les
plus chaleureux
c'est david obadia alors pour cette
nouvelle année je ne fais pas dans votre
nouveau je ne souhaite simplement peut
être ce que nous voulons que notre jeu
nous souhaitons à tout moment parce que
la guérison de tous dépend de la
garnison de chacun belron joubel bonsoir
à tous et malika qui cas pas les bases
hot
mangini vous souhaitez autres en bon
ça manque à souhaiter c'est jerry's on
élévation réconciliation et pico nous
mêmes et puis bah nous les points d
avance et on nourrit v / pdp légal et
pour cette nouvelle année vous souhaite
de passer le plus de temps et vos
proches prendre soin de vous et quoi
qu'il arrive continuer d'avancer
il me reste pour ma part à vous formulez
ou non de martinique la première nos
plus sincères voeux pour cette année
2021 de cette année soit des plus
heureuses en ce qui vous concerne
quant à nous on se revoit l'année
prochaine
[Musique]
e